schön dass sie dabei sind in dieser
historischen woche der woche der
kanzlerwahl olaf scholz hat sein vater
gerade verraten wollte schon mit zwölf
kanzler werden jetzt hat es endlich
geschafft ja im grunde peinlich wenn man
dafür 51 jahre braucht aber klar besser
spät als nie jetzt wurde der
machtwechsel vollzogen und zwar deutsch
also routiniert stinklangweilig und ohne
dass irgendwer wahlbetrugs schreit kann
man heutzutage richtig stolz drauf sein
olaf scholz ist seit mittwoch unser
neunter bundeskanzler der vierte von der
spd und in seiner heimat endgültig kult
seit 39 jahren betreibt recht hätten
hier seinen friseursalon einen olaf
scholz haarschnitt für 499 dieses
angebot gibt es wohl nur in hamburg
altona
zu glücken oder
499 für einmal mit dem rasierer oder die
plätte das konnte ich locker mit dem
oliver welke haarschnitt für 99 cent ich
muss bekloppt sein so eins muss man
meinem glatzen bruder allerdings lassen
er hat seine notorische mekka partei die
alte tante spd in eine leise vor sich
hin schnurrende machtmaschine verwandelt
ja sogar die jusos fressen scholz aus
der hand jetzt wo kevin kühnert
generalsekretär wird ja und das obwohl
die klassischen spd themen steuern und
verteilungsfragen im ampel programm kaum
vorkommen nur harmonie wo du auch
hinguckt und kostbare geschenke für alte
und neue herrscher frühere spd kanzler
schröder bekam zigarren scholz viele
blumen und äpfel zum abschied bekommt
merkel noch wanderstöcke und eine
brotdose
sich zehn jahre machst du dich kaputt
für dieses land und da gibt es eine
prognose es ist so erst nach 20 jahren
kriegt man wohl den thermomix so wir
könnten jetzt hier die einzelnen
ressorts im neuen ampel kabinett
durchgehend nancy faeser oder klara
geywitz aber hey die fans interessieren
sich doch eh nur für den einen oder ja
natürlich unser vorzeitiges
weihnachtsgeschenk karl lauterbach ist
doch gesundheitsminister warum scholz
das entschieden hat ist klar
damit karl vor lauter arbeit mit markus
lanz schluss macht deutschlands bester
pandemie erklärer muss jetzt plötzlich
die pandemie managen toi toi toi sogar
das ausland kriegt sich gar nicht mehr
ein ehepaar das kann laut dabei karl
lauterbach beim hkj apa hat so kann laut
karl lauterbach spd
experte karl lauterbach
lauterbach macht jetzt kurzen prozess
mit omikron ja natürlich gegen dr du mir
hat das virus nicht den hauch einer
chance aber
klar jetzt muss der lauterbach liefern
vor allem impfstoff und ganz wichtig
karl damit nicht alle aus dem fenster
springen vielleicht auch mal fröhlich
klingen wie irgendwas sagen was den
menschen mut macht hier seien allererste
auftritt als minister das würde ein
wichtiges land werden wir müssen diese
pläne bekämpfen die plane länger dauern
als viele denken auch karl wirklich mal
ernsthaft dritter satz und direkt wieder
depri stimmung ja man könnte auch sagen
er bleibt sich treu und so verliert die
heute schon nach martin sonneborn und
nico selbst schon den dritten
mitarbeiter an die politik ist schade
wirklich schade wobei in die neuen
kollegen in berlin schon sehr nett
aufgenommen haben vom staatssekretär gab
es zur belohnung eine brotdose
viel toller was gibt man einem minister
mit auf den weg nämlich einen
nussknacker weil der minister alleine
diese müsse nicht wird meistern können
einen zweiten akku der ihnen ermöglicht
sehr harte und dicke nüsse zu knacken
diese harten nüsse diese harten müsse
durchaus sehr harte und dicke küsse ich
habe die härtesten und größten müsse in
ganz berlin
an glückwunsch so wenn ich mir die
lebensläufe unseres neuen kabinetts an
guckt dann ist das eine ziemliche rookie
regierung was an sich okay es als symbol
für neuanfang und aufbruch mit cem
özdemir hat deutschland erstmals ein
minister mit türkischen wurzeln ist
überfällig während zum beispiel der
osten einmal mehr chronisch
unterrepräsentiert ist wobei das
wichtigste in der berichterstattung zum
kabinett leider tut unter geht das
kabinett scholz junge moderne zur hälfte
frauen aber was das aller geilste ist in
dieser regierung arbeitet erstmals kein
einziger bayer
deutschland dreht durch vorfreude und
feiert den tag der befreiung von
geknackten csu ideen es ist der freedom
day endlich kann der durchgeknallte
bayerische sonnenkönig seine schlimmsten
pflegefälle nicht mehr als minister in
berlin entsorgen knalltüten wie ihn oder
ihn hier
jahrelang habt ihr uns deutsche
terrorisiert mit geistigen dünnschiss
die herdprämie mütter rente oder
ausländer maut aber jetzt jetzt ist
endlich vorbei ganz genau das erste
komplett barrierefreie kabinett seit 72
jahren danke apple
gab es noch nie ein komplett neues
kabinett und was die ehemaligen csu
stars angeht manche sind seit dieser
woche nur noch einfache abgeordnete
andere wurden gnadenlos verrentet der
horst zum beispiel warte mal das heißt
wir können ja auch das blasorchester
dass wir immer für billige bayern wird
es in der kulisse haben feuern
ihr seid raus
hierdurch
ja zum letzten mal dabei die
regensburger arbeitslosen bitte geht
jetzt ausdrücklich nicht gegen die
bayerische kultur obwohl ich prophezeie
meine damen und herren mit der harmonie
in der ampel ist es bald vorbei zoff ist
vorprogrammiert und zwar wegen
außenpolitik natürlich annalena baerbock
kündigte eine härtere gangart gegenüber
autokraten aus russland oder china
seit dem wein die sich vor angst in den
schlaf allerdings betrachtet olaf scholz
das muss man wissen außenpolitik als
chefsache und nord stream 2 zum beispiel
war ja von anfang an auch ein spd
projekt grüßen gerd schröder den alten
gas vertreter weshalb dessen erbe also
olaf der erste bei putin kritik auch
nicht so richtig auf den tisch haut
schon die
widerrechtliche inversion in der krim
oder auf der krim hat ja weit über die
krim hinaus
sorgen bei allen produziert
das produziert sorgen wenn jemand ein
anderes land einfach cloud wer wüsste
das besser als wir deutschen aber diese
sorgen sollen uns ja nicht nord stream
vermiesen nein
weil keine frage jetzt aussteigen wäre
wohl ein finanzielles desaster
andererseits bei einem krieg in der ost
ukraine wird schwierig auf der alten
röhre hierzu waren ähnlich vorsichtig
formuliert olaf scholz auch beim thema
china dort finden ab februar die
olympischen winterspiele statt
allerdings ohne amerikanische politiker
die usa haben wegen der schweren
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china
stichwort uiguren einen diplomatischen
boykott beschlossen und dem haben sie
inzwischen viele andere länder
angeschlossen carolin kebekus meldet
sich live aus dem olympischen ski
zentrum in der nähe von peking caroline
wie reagieren die chinesen
oliver hier geht erst mal alles seinen
geregelten gang da vorne zb wird gerade
die große chance fürs skispringen
vorbereitet und weil die chinesen nichts
dem zufall überlassen wenn es um
sicherheit geht schicken sie heute erst
mal testweise hongkonger oppositionelle
runter natürlich mit zusammengebundenen
scheren wir sind hier noch ganz
entspannt und voller vorfreude kennen
sie schon das maskottchen der panda
bienen die wende wenn sie trinkt er voll
süß in den taiwanesischen luftraum ein
hoya recht niedlich meine sie
deutschland sollte sich dem
diplomatischen boykott anschließen sehr
gute frage wurde olaf scholz neulich
gleich dreimal gestellt und versuchen
sie doch bitte mal seine antwort zu
verstehen nachdem herr scholz jetzt zwei
man nicht geantwortet hat wird sich
deutschland einem diplomatischen boykott
der winterspiele anschließen wir finden
dass es wichtig ist dass man alles dafür
tut dass die welt international
zusammenarbeitet und alle maßnahmen die
man jeweils ergreift müssten sorgfältig
abgewogen werden in einer welt die
zusammenarbeiten muss geht es auch darum
dass man die signale der zusammenarbeit
nutzt
jetzt als t shirt nicht im heute auf ein
shop die perfekte antwort auf alle
menschenrechtsfragen wir finden dass es
wichtig ist dass man alles dafür tut
dass die welt international zusammen
arbeiteten alle maßnahmen die man jemals
eingreift müssen sorgfältig abgewogen
werden in einer welt die zusammenarbeit
muss geht es auch darum dass man die
signale der zusammenarbeit nutzt
bedeutet absolut nichts naja aber der
deutsche ton wird sich jetzt ja deutlich
verschärfen mit annalena baerbock
nein olaf scholz hat dem chinesischen
präsidenten schon ausrichten lassen kein
witz dass er die chinapolitik merkels
beibehalten will seine chinakritischen
koalitionspartner werde er zitat
inhalten mit anderen worten lasst mensch
im all aber am ende redet sowieso oder
papa aussenpolitik ist was für
erwachsene dass bernburg schöne darf aus
dem flieger steigen und winkel und gut
aussehen ok berbalk ausgebootet verstehe
was ist mit thomas bach unserem
deutschen ioc präsidenten könnte ja
nicht mal den chinesen eine klare ansage
machen ja doch
wir können uns alle auf die großartige
chinesische gastfreundschaft und die
effizienz der organisation freuen die
hat das chinesische volk schon so oft
bewiesen
absolut diese berühmte effizienz mit der
sie allein die ganzen umerziehungslager
für millionen von uiguren hochziehen
auch dazu kein kritisches wort von ioc
oliver ich weiß es klingt jetzt total
crazy aber könnte man große
sportveranstaltungen nicht zur
abwechslung auch mal in demokratien
stattfinden lassen oder nur als
unverbindlicher denkanstoß wo ist das
zdf wirklich von diesem spiel berichten
oder von der sklaven wm nächstes jahr in
katar man kann ja normal weil ich
aussetzen und sagen kommen wird seinen
stattdessen alte folgen von diese
drombuschs auch eine
menschenrechtsverletzung aber wenigstens
lustig sorry ich frag ja nur jetzt muss
auch erlaubt sein hallo
[Musik]
kinder ich hoffe die kamera läuft denn
ich halte nicht an abonniert den kanal
hier danke euer gernot hassknecht so ich
gehe wieder nach hause
schönen feierabend jürgen zschau